m je vais vérifier que tout marche pour
le manger pas encore les échiquiers mais
ça va arriver avec le début des parties
ce sont les olympiades en ligne
on va écrire le score en bas
encore
donc c'est chine chine russie
et on va et on va mettre le score petit
à petit je vérifier que tout est vrai
tout est bien démarré je vais mourir le
chat
pour pouvoir parler avec vous et on va
voir on va voir les équipes on va voir
on va voir ce qu'ils jouent ce qui a été
à nu ce qui a été aligné aujourd'hui
terrible
donc c'est la première demi finale de la
journée chine russie et après on aura
etats unis inde à 17h30 je crois
pour le moment il n'y a personne si à
ludwig
on n'est que deux à ben bravo hein
ç'a valu de ligue 1 du coup on peut se
parler tranquille
c'est les plus beaux live
ses chevaux là ils salivent à yuya
personne au monde peut se parler
tranquille à l'ancienne comme ça fait
toujours plein en fait
alors par contre en fait sur le truc
live duchess comme pour le moment il
n'ya pas les parties en fait ça s'est un
peu complexe parce que parce que parce
que ça joue surtout chasse comme
donc tant qu'il ya pas les parties là je
peux pas y faire grand chose
ça devrait arriver à ça y est c'est
parti il y avait un bug écoutez on va
regarder dingli rennes contre double off
est par contre pourquoi je les ai pas là
à droite
ça ça va être très problématique en fait
bon c'est problématique pour changer
d'échiquier pourra voir les scores en
fait
ça va être difficile pour le score mais
en tout cas voilà on a on à la partie
d'iggy rennes
contre doivent donc on voit que les
équipes ont sont bien loin d'avoir mis
leurs meilleurs joueurs un double of il
n'est pas numéro 1 pas numéro 2 pas
numéro 3 il est sûrement numéro cinq ou
six pour l'équipe de russie donc qu'il
ya et artemiev dont il ya deux deux
joueurs mixte puis il ya deux filles
donc deux joueurs mx2 fille puis un
junior
fit une junior fier et un junior
1 juniors garçons normalement
on n'arrive pas à trouver pour le moment
on n'arrive pas à trouver pour le bon
pour voir rester sur sur la partie de
double of
a par contre ce qui est bien c'est que
sur le live officiel ils n'ont pas
trouvé les parties où on est les seuls à
voir les parties des amis au je crois
que les autres live les ont pas on est
complètement au dessus du game on est
complètement tu dis et je crois que les
autres live les ont pas trouvées on est
les seuls les a retrouvés au c'est
magnifique si c'est le cas oh ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir les amis on est
les seuls à voir les parties
on est beaucoup plus futés il y à un bug
mais nous on a réussi à un peu débugger
le truc et oui des français peuvent voir
le match
magnifique
ça fait tellement plaisir
bible
bon du coup ça ajoute elle est la petite
variante avec fo f5 fou g6 ils ont pas
les game sur les autres live c'est
magnifique
c'est pas possible
il regarde pas les parties quoi c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique
ça fait plaisir
ça fait toujours très plaisir
c'est quoi l'enjeu de ce tournoi aucun
zig c'est des olympiades en ligne ça
sert à rien en fait
enfin je veux dire qu'il ya personne qui
prend trop la compet au sérieux sauf le
kazakhstan vlad hier en sueur c'est bien
pour les sponsors
c'est pour le fun ouais c'est ça
c'est pour le fun l'année dernière non
mais l'année dernière s'était bel compet
là je troll
l'année dernière c'était magnifique
parce que il ya deux matches décisifs
qui sont joués à la connexion internet
ça c'était beau au beau ça ça fait
plaisir les peut-être si ça joue sur un
mix clic peut-être
cg qui prit juin compris ouais il ya 2 2
mx 2 filles 1 junior et une junior fille
ingénieurs mixte 1 juniors filles c'est
complètement hybride
c'est magnifique en fait
c'est vraiment magnifique
et oui la connexion n'avait pas tenu et
du coup comme l'inde avait perdu sur
connexion il avait décidé de donner le
titre deux équipes ça ça avait été
extraordinaire serre que l'un d'eux père
la connexion internet perdre le match à
cause de ça et la fidh intervient une
heure après le match pour dire que
finalement les olympiades auront deux
vainqueurs donc la finale la finale
il ya deux médailles d'or en fait
c'était vraiment très très beau
ça c'était vraiment magnifique donc
j'espère qu'on pourra revivre pareil
scénario
c'était vraiment incroyable histoire
magnifique c'est un très très beau
moment de sport ça qu'on a vu qu'on
avait vécu ensemble l'année dernière
meiway la technique de couper la boxe
soi qui peut être une belle technique
mais c'est génial en fait je vous assure
que sur le live officiel il regarde
toujours pas légalement fait je vous
jure il y a que nous qui regardons les
game c'est magnifique
c'est absolument magnifique
on va rester sur la game peut-être on va
aller un peu sur la game
de dart et nief contre ue
oui cavaliers à trois mois jvg examen
dans 20 minutes bonne chance hein
c'est pour ça que je suis venu ici en
fait ça parce que nous on a les games et
les ont pas oui mais on est des marlou
des andins
bref c'est beau c'est c'était beau et
tout le monde était vainqueur peut-être
un petit quart aller à 3 pour du
cavalier bassinko
vous êtes pour qu'ils aient plus tôt
pour la chine ou pour la russie
vous avez plutôt pour quel team
genre monsieur wayne simmonds matin
frérot je me lave à huit heures du matin
pour le temps de faire tout ce que je
fais je me couche à 1h30 donc
à ce jour six heures la nuit et je fais
une heure de sieste la journée je fais
cette heure de sommeil en général plutôt
pour l'allemagne ah bah oui arménie
belle équipe un
super vidéo d'art ce matin ouais c'était
cool
c'était cool bon alors si fait cavaler à
3 km et 5 1
à vis des autres atteint était vraiment
bien
fait quattro
dans le cas et toi tu es pour qui
réussit
après petit truc quoi pour savoir s'il
ya du monde sur un stream vu les trucs
de chasse comme tv un petit conseil
regardez toujours le nombre de pseudo
qui a dans le tchat non ça c'est pas ça
c'est le match d'hier ok les parties
sont apparus
donc ouais ok maintenant je peux les
avoir facilement voir regarder sur le
nombre de pseudo qui a dans un chat
parce que en fait le truc avec chaises
comme tv
c'est que c'est que des fois vous avez
l'impression que surtout sur les stream
américain en fait sur les streams
français - mais on peut avoir
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de viewer
mais en fait que vous allez si vous
pouvez être à 4500 5000 joueurs et si
vous regardez le nombre d'utilisateurs
de chat pour marquer qui en a beaucoup
moins à
genre avec l'expérience vous allez
remarquer genre sur ma chaîne perso
c'est dur s est tu as telecom via
ustream et et ça en fait si vous voulez
savoir où il ya du heurt en fait en
général que ce soit n'importe quel ce
crime soit sur un stream échec ou sur un
sur autre chose il faut toujours aller
regarder le
dans le chat les utilisateurs et salua
you
donc c'est vrai pour tout le monde ce
serait pour moi c'est vrai pour as you
c'est vrai pour hikaru c'est vrai pour
n'importe quel streamer en fait
est alors en français comme je disais ça
fait une très petite différence ça fait
200 300 viewer ici de chasse comme a pas
de bug et pour les stream anglais ça
fait 4 5 milliards de différence donc
c'est vraiment beaucoup
juste pour dire que cet ouvrage est en
attente du rsa ça marche aussi pour les
premières pages switch parfois quand on
en première patch switch on a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de vue genre je sais qu'en france est
une première page switch ça peut faire
entre
1500 et 4000 viewer de plus c'est une
première page sur pour un gros événement
qui est surtout les
pour tous les utilisateurs peut être
même même encore plus que 4000 vue mais
il se voit pas dans le chat non plus
donc c'est pour ça que regarder le
nombre d'utilisateurs dans le chat ça
permet de
ça permet de se faire un meilleur avis
quand il ya des chiffres qui peuvent
paraître un petit peu différent de ce
que vous avez vu les jours précédents
c'est un petit truc de pro en fait pour
savoir
et généralement c'est plutôt utilisé
pour savoir pour ses propres stream que
pour les stream des autres formats je
regarde pour mon stream perso quand je
commence alors beaucoup de joueurs
viewer d'un seul coup je veux je préfère
savoir genre par exemple pour les
battles avant tout d'un coup monté à 7,8
milles si cette fille me lever pour
l'essab battles et pour être sûr en fait
je regardais qui est vraiment beaucoup
de gens qui s'y intéressent et c'était
le cas mais voilà c'est un truc qui est
fait pour être sûr
ça vous a intéressé 1 de vous dire ce
petit truc en vrai on s'en fout on n'est
plus là pour regarder les échecs
mais
mais voilà comme il y avait la question
dans le chat le fixa pouvait en
intéresser certains donc là le fou à
partir en b2 il veut jouer pour des 5
c'est pas mal qu'il ait mis les pions
sur blanc sur que les pions soit sur
noir c'est difficile pour les noirs
d'attaqué sur blanc donc c'est vrai
qu'on va pouvoir en même envoyé du f4f
sinko j'aime bien les blancs ici
et je pense la chine est favorite parce
que ding il est par exemple des
problèmes de connexion après souvent en
chine meding est plus fort que doug of
your heart emi est fauqué artemiev un
peu plus fort
mais willy fans sadr est au dessus de
gharyane china
world c'est dur à dire et chinois tu
sais jamais trop comment ça joue mais
c'est pas sûr qu'ils savent moins fort
qui s'y prennent qu'aux
shuvalova as well as petit nine cailloux
aller 1884 mais j'ai déjà vu jouer ça
doit jouer à 2000 2003 2004 easy
et kosteniuk jouanne jun ouais en fait
le ya le facteur internet qui fait qu'il
est là où ils sont peut-être plus
habitués mais sinon sinon les chinois
c'est quand même assez fort
c'est quoi l'autre demie alors ce sera à
17h30 et c'est un de quelque chose
c'est inde états unis
la france la france a déjà éliminé un
édito
oui on sait pas trop présente et même si
le prez jouer
d'une cailloux 2310 en longues m c'était
sûr en fait j'ai déjà vu jouer nine
cailloux en fait c'est pour ça que je
sais qu'elle joue beaucoup mieux elle
doit même joué mieux que 23 70 et c'est
pour ça que j'étais étonné de son lots
mais après tu as des joueurs qui jouent
peu en chine donc ils peuvent avoir un
hello vraiment très très faible par
rapport à leur niveau mais à minimes
c'est juste que je connais j'étais juste
étonné de la voir à sept lots mais tu
sais pas si j'aurais peut-être dû pour
des championnats chino genre de truc et
j'avais pas fait gaffe à son à son et
l'ofii j'avais plus fait gaffe à son as
sont les vols parce qu'elle me
paraissait vraiment être une chose
intéressante
il fait la reine ce soir est une arène
ce soir je suis pas au courant
y at il des bons joueurs belges away
la mrh 3g 4 f4
peut-être une telle poussée pions pour
ding bon c'est dur à suivre parce qu'à
six parties en même temps c'est du 15 +
10 donc c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
difficile de suivre les parties de
suivre les matches c'est vrai qu'il ya
peut y avoir des formats par équipes qui
sont plus plus visuel mais faut-il
encore regardé les bonnes chaîne twitch
salue lui 6
1 un vrai temps appartient thriller
français on attend cela avec impatience
ben oui tout pendant l'
extraordinaire en tout cas j'ai pu voir
l'intervention de vlad ce matin en
replay cinq ans mais à quel point il est
intéressant quel que soit le sujet qu'il
aborde ça va être agréable de boire une
bière avec lui si tu n'en boit qu'une
allée faire formation battle bas soit
formation de battles où les joueurs
jouent les uns après les autres et le
score augmente puisque du coup tu suis
soit le format qu'on avait fait
samedi dernier pour le match contre les
bras le team battle où on partage le
temps et les joueurs jouent les uns
après les autres l'un ou l'autre en fait
qu'ils sont des formats qui sont plus
faciles à suivre lie à six parties en
même temps ça joue en rapide honnêtement
de même même à mon niveau j'ai pas le
temps suivre en fait il ya trop de
partis partout et on a on n'a pas le
temps juste on n'a juste pas le temps
c'est
c'est juste impossible en fait je vous
assure que même pour un procès pas
vraiment possible de tous de suivre le
match correctement
parce qu'il ya des riches qui est
partout en fait faudrait tourner comme
ça non-stop
fait pas on sait que montre cette étude
si j'ai dit avant-hier en live
ça régulatrice ce format non
mais les joueurs ou une caméra derrière
il ya deux caméras donc là
automatiquement ses safe
bah disons que suivre deux trois partis
ont rapide généralement c'est déjà
difficile moi je m'arrête à deux maxi 3
ça doit être faisable en commentant écho
plus mais six c'est impossible en fait
c'est pas super actif d'avoir tous les
âges qui assure je trouve encore une
fois un format bof alors là hélios et
leur fausser un format phare l'un c'est
un format ça qu'on voit depuis peut-être
une quarantaine d'années déjà où une
cinquantaine d'années qui existait en
longue mais bon il n'y avait pas de
public à l'époque pour les matchs par
équipe en partie mais qui a été
récupérée pour pour tous les tournants
en réel en fait par équipe donc c'est
systématiquement impossible de suivre
pour à moins que tu sois vraiment dans
le match que tu sois capitaine de
l'équipe ou quoi mais à regarder en mode
spectateur c'est absolument impossible
de tout suivre parce que pat à six
parties en même temps quoi faudrait
vraiment faire ça non-stop en fait
poursuivre et essayer de regarder qui
qui a joué le dernier coup il ya eu un
truc grave en fait si moi je regardais
ça je regarderai comme ça si je voulais
vraiment suivre on lie à 5 qui s'est pas
passé grand chose et tu vas et tu
reviens en fait
mais en vrai mise à part faire ça tu
peux pas tu peux pas sûr autrement mais
évidemment c'est un comment table parce
que tu regardes comme tu regardes quoi
mais du coup et oui c'est eux c'est
normal si vous êtes rapidement perdu et
s'il est très difficile de suivre
c'est tout à fait normal serait qu'un
suivent six matchs de foot en même temps
où le score bouge de partout il ya des
occases en fait tu vois plus rien quoi
enfin c'est le format phare
c'est pas mal d'avoir toutes les parties
tu peux dire c est que tu as aimé vu
qu'elles sont interdépendantes les unes
aux autres benno ben tu sais pas en fait
ça ce qui se passe dans cette part est
le match dépend des autres partis
il peut pas y avoir un duplex balaïa 6
échiquier en même temps donc ça c'est un
saint sysplex qua non c'est vrai je vous
assure même pour un procès impossible à
suivre correctement
après comme je vous dis nous quand on
regarde les matches parce qu'on veut
savoir on tourne beaucoup les échiquiers
en fait
on l'a en tout cas ça tarde pas trop mal
se passer
côté du boeuf
ça l'air de pas mal se passer côté du
golfe
bon cette structure c'est pas très grave
on en avait déjà parlé dans un live
on ça va égaliser ça ça devrait faire
nul à la fin on pourra suivre plus
facilement mais les coûts iront plus
vite
ça c'est chaud
en fonction de ce que font les
coéquipiers vrai il faut pousser ou
jouer
ça j'aime bien où il fallait le pion à
6,6 fait plaisir là
bon ça peut-être un peu mieux pour la
joueuse chinoise ici
complexe ici
turbo d'euros
ça peut jouer là dessus et ce que les
gens ont peut voir les parties des
équidés coéquipiers
oui mais ça te déconcentre donc c'est
pas forcément bien de le faire
c'est pas forcément bien faire
c'est peut-être bien pour pour artemiev
en fait si on prend qui on prend food et
6 et 5 peut-être cru comme ça
c'est quoi les met sur d'arbitrage
genton à ses deux caméras une devant une
derrière et à partage d'écran gros
combien en poche l'équipe qui gagne je
crois qu'il ya pas d'argent au yoyo et
ustream à ustream je pense que les
équipes sont payés par leur fédération
c'est de l'argent public je pense
je crois parce que j'ai pas vu de prize
pool
comme les olympiades en réalité un les
olympiades ont ré en réel n'y a pas de
il ya quelques petits prix individuels
ou quoi mais en gros c'est celle
fédérations qui paye c'était un pot quoi
ou la fédération n'ont pas vraiment et
impôts mais les licences
ça dépend des pays
ça dépend des pays je pensais plutôt les
licences que les impôts mais bon après
les fédérations des aides publiques donc
in fine est de toute façon
en quelque sorte ya forcément une partie
de ton argent qui va dedans mais là
c'est pas nos équipes donc je sais pas
là c'est pour la russie et la chine sait
pas du tout comment ça se passait bien
utilisé peut-être des impôts des russes
et des chinois j'en sais rien moi
c'est pas comme en marche leur leur
système fédéral merci à lyon qu'à
ackermann pour pour le savent
castaing match avec vlad ce serait
magnifique ça
merci bas voitures volées limitation
alors ouais le président on comprend
pourquoi il a perdu
après il ya peut-être des sponsors je
sais pas exactement comment marche cette
compétition ce que fait rire c'est que
générallement pour pour les olympiades
et cetera se sont à
[Musique]
ce sont les fédé qui équipaient
à toi c'est toi je me posais cette
question est-ce que ce cloître fait mal
ou pas j'avais l'impression que ça
gagner au il ya un coup de fouet j'ai vu
avec le redis ici très haut noir
ça a été fait froid il a trouvé ça pas
été raté mes
preuves c'est incroyable que ça tienne
c'est fou l3 damas de et tours à huit
pour refaire clouage incroyable
ok il a dû le voir un en amont mais
énorme défense la
face et une énorme défense
ça c'est réellement une énorme défense
trouvé par par you
dig meilleur joueur du tournoi ah bah
oui forcément puisqu'il est numéro trois
mondial et qui a personne du top niveau
qui joue à part lui
donc oui jouer thème powell jouer tempo
parce qu'il avait vu en benoît
ça ça va faire drôle ou bof deans a
affaire digne du boss affaires draw
willy fans elle va mettre petite
pression
kosteniuk à
c'est pouce aux têtes ou pas non je sais
pas ça doit l'air d'être assez égal il
va peut-être y avoir quatre nuls ont ici
ça c'est l'ère des turbo d'euros c'est
peut-être l'échiquier junior féminin qui
va qui va tout jouer
ils ont ramené leurs meilleures équipes
les chinois huawei mais ils n'ont pas la
meilleure connexion la meilleure équipe
mais pas la meilleure fibre ils n'ont
pas free ils n'ont pas tout compris
la leçon que les blancs sont mieux en
fait
hein alors dit propose ça y propose tout
reprend dame prend tour à 8 pour refaire
une enfilade dame prend 1,8 fou prend à
8 tours prend à
8,3 cette fougue 4 mais j'adore les
blancs dans cette position tu vas faire
tomber huit tours bessette j'ai
l'impression d'être à deux doigts de
gagner
c'est très très dur à jouer pour pour
les noirs c'est pour ça qu'il rentre pas
là dedans
ah non artemiev qui doit être mieux
du coup les russes sont peut-être bien
attention à des russes sont peut-être en
train de gagner le premier match
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont plus de
pouce est en fait il va vraiment falloir
que cailloux
selon lev de la chaussure
elle était jolie celle là où elle était
jolie celle là
aulaqi a eu fort qu'il s'enlève de
laquelle cela relève de la chaussure
elle est quand même très joli or vous
pouvez pas dire non dans le chat c'est
interdit
ça passe un ça ça passe un
nom elle passe elle passe elle passe
donc digne du bof ça fait nul artemiev
ça va gagner will find gacina ça va être
chaud mais ça c'est un jeu de mots pour
les gens qui sont russophones
kosteniuk jouanne jun
les poussettes blanc mais il va rien à
voir wang
huang il va faire
échouer à novak cailloux ça va être
chaud ouais ça va jouer surtout valois
cailloux pour pour les chinois
c'est complexe
3h cette
basse erreurs de retransmission sa
erreur de retransmission de et oui c'est
magnifique les erreurs de retransmission
sur sur un évène qui est jouée sur
chasse comme ça fait plaisir
fou 4 est sûre j'ai six tours b 8 donc
il va y avoir f5 mais ça va donner des
cadeaux au cheval
mais peut-être faire du food et si ça
après je sais pas les gars c'est pas si
clair c'est pas si con
way non ça va arrête ça va être chaud ce
match les amis ça peut se jouer à la
connexion ce serait beau
allez on va espérer une petite déco la
déco missclick
une déco à miss clic les amis
c'est tout ce qu'on veut voir
adecco me fixa ferait plaisir
voire même les deux
un mystique puis déco quoi
c'est dommage pour les blancs ne pas
avoir poussé
6.8 rouge et six en fait
mais fou sait si j'en verrais bien je
sais pas si c'est fou ces six fou des
six tours 8 quand même
j'aurais envie d'envoyer
vos fraises fraîches trois fois à cinq
mais surtout des six du coup il a plu le
tour huit amis la tourache huit
cavaliers j'ai su ce qui allait prendre
sept gros hockey hockey
vizela nul ça ne me fait pas peur c'est
magnifique il a visé la nulle
il a visé la font quoi c'est magnifique
ça lui a pas du tout fait peur
voilà ses pions plus pour les noirs mais
c'est drôle oui les fans mariage qui n'a
ça c'est quand même pression blanc
ça c'est drôle
et ça j'ai l'impression cailloux al séni
mal
elle est en train de s'égratigner le
droit de pied cailloux
se passe pas bien pour cailloux
ça m'a l'air de mal se passer pour la
chine mais bon tout peut encore se
retourner
voilà je pense qu'il va y avoir tour est
le 8 et s'échange de tourelles leroy qui
va venir en d6 le pion qui peut
qui peut être
annonce aveu aller
complexe
ça ça va être droit
ça va jouer sur la junior féminine mais
je comprends pas trop le délire perso de
faire jouer à des juniors des juniors
féminins des féminines va c'est un petit
peu comme si on faisait une ligue 1 de
foot étaient obligés d'aligner des moins
de 14 des filles moins de 16 et de faire
des équipes hybride avec concevoir je
trouve ça un peu space perso mais après
surtout que les échecs sont mixtes de
base
je trouve ça un petit peu particulier
surimpression c'est assez
c'est cool de mettre les meilleurs
contre les meilleurs quoi
passe comme si au rugby tu faisais le
ch'ti nation et que aux six nations il y
avait des juniors des machins fin ce
serait bizarre quoi
alaïa peut-être tourelles à huit
cavaliers bessette et tour lb 8
on faire via près mais je sais pas river
starz
ouais j'ai l'impression que les chinois
se font marcher dessus
curan exit le périnée parler d'eux et
chic et mixtes et chic mx va être c'est
chic et mixtes avaient jeté féminin vs
échiquier féminin et ainsi de suite quoi
le junior contre le junior et tout quoi
une idée j'ai manqué de force à
apprendre des joueurs 2e i oi je
suis pas fan de système on t'oblige à
apprendre des gens par limite d'âge par
afin je trouve ça un peu bizarre quoi
rappelons que les compétitions
normalement c'est les meilleurs du pays
vs les meilleurs du pays enfin
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout de savoir qui
a le meilleur junior quoi
à angres aux juges que j'ai pas
d'exemple de sport où ça se passe comme
ça où tu es obligé de mettre un junior
tu obligé de mettre deux filles étaient
obligés de mettre en juniors filles 1
juste ça me paraît un peu bizarre quoi
année tu regardes ce soir lille wolsburg
tu te retrouves avec des joueurs au
moins deux des joueurs de moins de 10 kw
à
la presse pour voir certains joueurs
ben non en fait tu veux voir les
meilleurs normalement quant à une
compétition avec les olympiades c'est
l'équivalent d'une coupe du monde pour
les échecs
donc c'est qu'à lui disait coupe du
monde de foot mais en fait non
sur les onze joueurs qui en a que deux
tu peux choisir que deux titulaires
entre guillemets normaux étaient tous
les autres tu vas avoir des restrictions
quoi ça me paraît étrange visuellement
mais après
c'est moi qui suis con aussi un
possible
et là on puisse ya vraiment beaucoup de
restrictions se seraient deux à mes deux
femmes je dirai rien je vois pourquoi
pas mais là les les juniors et juniors
filles trouvent que ça ce
campus a autant d'importance que les
échiquiers best
travailler sur les formats bah ouais
mais
pas feint pas toujours ça c'est pas vrai
d'ailleurs qu'on sait bien c'est bien
mais
il se trouve que c'est c'est quand même
très très spécial
c'est fatigant à force bah ouais mais
bon
si on peut rien y faire un c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça
si à chaque fois tu as des trucs qui
font aucun sens logique
s'il peut rien mais là c'est quand même
assez assez spécial en tout cas c'est
les russes là qu'ils vont gagner
après quoi ils pourraient faire
l'échiquier junior mais qui compte moins
je sais pas vrai
que c'est mieux qu'à l'air bien well as
a l'air d'être bien partout pour les
russes en fait
le seul danger serait que ça choque un
peu ici
parce qu'à côté du que ça a l'air d'être
gagnants
donc ça et nul aussi
ça
devrait faire nul
gagner ça devrait faire nul ok en fait
ça va jouer sur celle là ça va jouer sur
l'échiquier féminin junior en fait très
clairement
ça c'est logique après parce que c'est
vrai que dans les échiquiers mixte et où
il va y avoir beaucoup plus de nul et il
ya beaucoup plus les joueurs sont
faibles pluies à partir et zulte hâtives
donc c'est logique que les matches se
jouent souvent sur les chics sur les
échiquiers féminin ou
échiquier junior ou junior fille en fait
les matches se jouent rarement sur les
plus forts entre les grosses équipes
donc ouais 7 sept parties peuvent faire
mal
faire jouer les meilleurs c'est un peu
trop charreaux fédé c'est juste ça je
pense c'est possible tout mais bon enfin
oui non mais tu as sûrement raison en
fait tout je pense que c'est vraiment ça
d'ailleurs les meilleurs dans la plupart
des pays joue parent c'est en fait c'est
les équipes qui ont réussi à mobiliser
des bons joueurs qui sont bien
mais notamment la france si on n'a ni
mvl n'y firent ou déjà en fait nous on
n'avait pas nos deux meilleurs joueurs
mais ah
ouais enfin bon mais du coup c'est vrai
que ça
[Musique]
va tu vraiment l'intérêt sportif du truc
quoi
complexe
4 normalement tu envoies la crème
d'habitude les olympiades c'est vraiment
la compétition par équipe par excellence
qui pour la peine est assez sympa où
tout le monde envoie ses meilleurs
joueurs un
bon là c'est full fautes 1 d'après le
redis c'est une gaffe par coup
c'est terrible en fait juste hors france
et 2 ça devait gagner
bêtement
sa prenez le pion et le pion des été
arrêté enfin gagner ça joue encore au
mais encore gaffe 17 sa prise food et 5
ha oui le coup c'était tout reprend des
5 et tour et tu en prends g5
qui était fort et fous des cinq sapeurs
instante
en fait sa menace rien pour être franc
c'est 2 à l'ena on fout des 5 c'est
énorme gaffe en fait c'est craquage ce
que fout des cinq ça attaque la tour
mais ça provoque tout reprend
c2c craquage
quand il n'y a pas de prix le seul
intérêt c'est de faire jouer les jeunes
corneilles l'expérience ça c'est vrai
tout mais le truc c'est que les jeunes
ils jouent entre eux ils jouent pas
contre les forts donc tu leur donnes pas
vraiment d'expérience non plus wells
effet mat et cheval au va et du coup
elles étaient quasi gagnante elle a
totalement de choc donc ça coûte et du
coup ça va jouer sur kosteniuk
kosteniuk est complètement gagnant est
donc ce sera jouée sur l'échiquier deux
féminins et l'échiquier féminin junior
en fait où il y aura eu des tchoco il y
aura eu des deux chocs ouais ça c'est
fait c'est terminé
le pur avancé gagné
donc ça se sera joué sur ces deux partis
ou à les autres ils ont fermé le jeu et
c'est sur ces deux échecs c'est un peu
gaffe et
après le truc c'est que tu es échiquier
junior juniors filles et féminin c'est
beaucoup plus aléatoire en fait plus les
niveaux sont bas puis les parties sont
aléatoires
s'enquiert en 1881 ça va faire mal de
points elo alors ça compte pas pour les
lots c'est pas une compétition assez une
compétition officielle mais qui comptent
pas pour le vélo
en tout cas pas pour le vélo l'on a mais
par contre chic su chi chi chu et à
craquer
ou pas
possible qu'ils craquent parce que là
maintenant il ya un pion passé j'ai qui
se dessine ça se peut qu'elles
soutiennent qu la gagne
je vois ce moment régulier s'épurant 2 -
ouais
surtout en rapide 1
bat donc ça se peut que ça choque sur le
junior chinois
et ça permettrait ici piano de
l'emporter donner le point la russie
g4 ça peut passer ici ouais c'est jouer
à gfg le pion est trop loin alors le roi
est encore dans le carré mais il va être
obligé de partir chercher le pion et du
coup le roi noir peut rentrer et gagner
le pion b4
il va y avoir un match retour à 13
heures pour être bien sûr
mais là évidemment ça commence à être
pion de plus
c4est là c'est gagné c'est complètement
gagné deux pions passé c'est trop
c'est assez assez facile à gagner ça
pour les noirs
a peut-être déco du russe
kosteniuk elle n'a pas encore gagné mais
s'arrête le cas maintenant
en 3h un ici et fort
qu'elle galère un peu
réf un dante un elle va avoir dames 1
ça ça va aider donc elle va faire dame
f4
bref deux dames c'est un force et elle
va faire dames 1
sylviane co qui galèrent
à terminer et kosteniuk aussi c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait la chine mène
1-0 pour le moment mais les deux les
deux parties restantes sont gagnantes
pour les russes à ne pas réussir à
mettre la dame en f3 la tour en f1 et ça
va être bon
ça 2 soit si c'est terminé sa abandon
et là ça va être abandon très bientôt
aussi
terrible
voilà ça va être des trois échecs 3b en
force et suroît b2 et cavaliers detroit
qui échangent lecavalier
donc il fait ça le cavalier va venir en
quatre maintenant puis leroy ans et
3,90 b2 cavaliers d2 et b1
donc avait lieu de forcer roi des trois
maintenant
et j'ai deux on part de ce côté-là
terrible un coup à gauche un coup à
droite un
coup à gauche un coup à droite un
cavalier f3 roi c3 maintenant on repart
de l'autre côté pour b2k et des deux
comme ça ça marche aussi un
cavalier g1 qui avait allégé 5 pour
prendre les cases de rebond du cavalier
héros af23 pranger imparable le cavalier
pourra pas partir
né sait les russes qui s'impose 2 1
les russes s'impose 2 1
on sait pas trop où le match a tourné
finalement à quel moment
ça choke côté côté chinois mais en tout
cas et si pierre nico a fait le taf dans
une finale très égal que c'est nous qui
a réussi à maintenir la pression et même
shuvalova qu'il ya plutôt craqué je
dirais pour pour la russie
ça n'a pas suffi à la à la chine pour
pour s'imposer dans ce dans ce premier
match et maintenant donc le match retour
la russie qui va avoir besoin
d'un match nul 1-1 3 partout qui
suffirait
quand l'échiquier junior ses formes
il ya une discipline quoi les chéquiers
juniors c'est même très fort
fyk
les autres pays c'est russie inde
on va attendre la suite un cédant 15
minutes le match retour on a plus qu'à
attendre
avec un 's&p' petites minutes ah oui il
faut que je mette les six minutes de
pause de pub j'allais oublier
j'allais oublier les 6000 de pub j'étais
pas loin de faire la connerie
heureusement que j'y pense
les six minutes de pub qui partent
en six minutes de pub
c'est beau
et petit pull parts
ça fait plaisir non
quand même très plaisir la petite pub
qui part
on va dans la face on n'a rien d'autre à
faire que d'attendre les amis
c'est des parties rapides way
parties rapides
magnifique je me fais trop les deux
partout avec ces olympiades grosse
ambiance à bas on attend malicieux qu'on
fasse en fait face et
on attend 1
est sale et anthony sont à prévoir aussi
quand je suis sur czech comme commis
stream sur youtube et twitter et 30
secondes de délai avec le chat donc
c'est un peu dur de discuter avec vous
aussi c'est une autre difficulté
complexe
du coup je regarde mon téléphone je fais
des trucs que j'ai à faire je veux
envoyer un mail à du coup je vais en
profiter pour le faire
on n'est pas prêt c'est vrai ça va
on n'est pas pressé là j'ai envie de
dire ouais
pas pressé du tout
vous pour la chine mais les joueurs
chinois ils vont pas bien sûr internet
systématiquement
alors je sais pas trop pourquoi
mais ouais on sent qu'ils jouent pas
beaucoup sur internet qu'ils ont souvent
des problèmes de connexion et tout donc
ils ont un peu de mal
c'est pas trop leur truc quoi
d'avoir du pied mais non c'est pas
l'heure
c'est pas leur truc
ça ne m'empêche pas de gagner parfois
des compètes mais c'est pas
c'est pas leur truc quoi
tel que vous sur des chutes chinois je
sais pas mais en tout cas
ils ont souvent perdu par deco quand
même après là ils sont en demi finale
mais à
[Musique]
jamais la petite pub
et ouais ça ça n'a pas du tout marché en
anglais non plus en fait cette
compétition
on peut dire qu'elle n'a pas été qu'elle
n'a pas été suivi
dans quelques langage que ce soit
ça passe a pas accroché quoi
ça a pas vraiment accroché vrai
merci car ce qu'anthony pour pour le
prime merci à toi
free oms pub de 30 secondes c'est pas
assez tout
c'est pas c'est
à 6 minutes c'est beau quand même
faudrait jamais de simic la deuxième
heure donc je remettrai un petit trois
minutes pendant les parties ça va partir
un
peu plus de l'europe tonga 100 % des
vidéos youtube terrible
à la vidéo de ce matin avec mathieu
était vraiment bien
la vidéo elle était vraiment vraiment
vraiment très intéressante pour la peine
ces genres de vidéos et de choses qui
font vraiment énormément progressé
pendant sept minutes
ouais c'est genre de parties qui sont
durs à comprendre mais à celles de
caravanes mais ces genres de parti qui
peut finir dans un livre en fête
ce que c'est des parties très très
intéressante
on attend un
petit quart d'heure
je pense que jah jah va rejoindre le top
mondial niveau final parce que hors
pratique à tous la suisse que j qui va
avec ah bah oui les jeunes encore après
il peut complètement implosé mais je
pense pas
mais ça lui fasse de fabrice salut à toi
attendre
encore 5 minutes
plus que cinq minutes d'attendre pour le
match retour donc on va être pour moi je
vais être pour la russie on va s'éviter
un tie break
on va tenter de s'éviter le tie break on
va être pour la russie dans le match
retour au tchad de bages c'est pour la
russie mais là d'autant plus
là d'autant plus
s'ils pouvaient plier le match serait
magnifique
on va espérer
ils peuvent le faire les russes
ça me plus que les russes d'ailleurs ce
constat j'ai la compétition a des gars
qui sont en demi finale et qui commande
tout l'événement depuis le début en se
faisant une méga arrive de succès
extraordinaires ils réussissaient 344
non mais c'est juste que c'est tu peux
pas intéresser les gens avec ça en fait
c'est pas possible
c
c'est terrible
c est terrible
emine
on
tiens
attendre la suite
afin qu'on soit marlou pendant que le
live officiels n'avaient pas les parties
mais c'est vrai qu'on les a eus pendant
les pendant 7 minutes ils ont pas réussi
à les récupérer alors que nous on a
réussi je vais être à l'affût en fait
bah on va attendre un
jeu presque envie de remettre une pub en
fait par plaisir
à jean mais une petite d'une minute
quand même je peux pas m'empêcher
je ne peux pas m'empêcher
fait plaisir dans cette petite pub là
qui part
désir
et je peux mettre pendant les parties
aussi un jeu correct et j'ai peut-être
vous mettre une petite trois minutes à
un moment donné pendant la partie ça ce
serait marlou quand même
jamais mentionné déconnectée parce que
ma chaîne n'est pas connecté pépé le
moko
well as plus de trois minutes pendant
bas on m'a dit qu'il fallait absolument
mettre 6 2 puis toutes les heures
peut-être j'envoie une trois minutes
pendant la demi et après pendant la
finale
ce serait beau
ça c'est magnifique
puis vent
j'en avais à carreaux of cause trop
périmés en vrai car je comprend un
disque à ce que disait fabre de fabrice
non mais ça peut être beau d'envoi une
petite six minutes une petite trois
minutes pendant la game façon sinon on
n'y arrivera pas à faire affaire les
12000 de pub sur le live on sera obligé
en fait
ça a commencé je suis tellement content
ça a commencé j'ai les parties avant le
truc officiel ça fait tellement plaisir
il sut ils ont pas les parties encore
sassus côté officiel
ils les ont après nous
ils les ont maintenant
c'est une petite catalan
donc là on est de nouveau à 0,01 sur ce
match là
donc c'est le match retour
alors si la russie réussit à refaire mal
sur les échiquiers féminin
et juniors
à le premier rang de ces 1 0 c'est
victoire de la russie dans le premier
match y'a pas de goal avérage
on était un peu ça fait trop longtemps
wedding y joue plus trop et là c'est
tournoi clairement
c'est pas son truc incitons à sur
internet adding il joue jamais bien donc
on verra quand il reprend les échecs en
réel
fonds à six dont qui tape sur le pion c4
complexe
trop pourquoi je dis complexe mais bon
je le dis quand même
peut-être des fous à trois qui peuvent
être intéressants
puis ces 5 pour passer le fou devant et
gêné
yun junghee artemiev
voir ce que ça donne des matchs qui n'a
oublié fans
solide joue à john kosteniuk
et ça ça peut être joué john qui
pressent cette fois-ci
et cailloux j'ai l'impression que les
couleurs sont plus intéressantes pour
pour les chinois cette fois ci
c'est quoi comme match c'est écrit dans
le titre non
et si jamais vous ces demi finales
quand même fait l'effort de mettre le
titre terrible
les pièces sur l'échiquier pas un scoop
complexe soit au niveau des points d'eau
les hommes si les femmes c'est
synchronisée genre 2005 savon à mais
c'est synchroniser les lots en gros
en gros synchronisée ouais y'a pas des
lots femmes et des lots aux roms en fait
les lots c'est mixte
pour quelles raisons les femmes et les
hommes ne joue pas entre les autres
alors non en fait ça deux catégories aux
échecs je vais leur expliquer pour la
millième fois mais à la catégorie mixte
qui inclut tout le monde et à la
catégorie féminine qui exclut les sommes
donc il ya deux catégories mais en fait
personne interdit aux femmes de jouer
aux hommes avec les hommes on interdit
aux hommes de jouer avec les femmes
enfin 5 faut comprendre en fait c'est
les femmes ne sont pas interdits de jeu
contre les hommes
elles peuvent très bien participer dans
les tournois mixtes
celle inverse qui est interdit
on tour c1 il va arriver à réfléchir à
hofu à 3 c 5
fessé 5 direct
qui est peut-être mieux d'ailleurs
il a dû hésiter voilà ça joue c'est plus
ou moins théoriques ça
casse et encore l'ouverture
ça c'est une pire que
fa - ouais ya des endroits des candidats
femmes pour savoir quelle femme
affrontera la championne du monde vrai
eh bien j'ai l'impression que ça tourne
plus les ouvertures en faveur de la
chine mais après
après gary foule afflue lina elle n'est
pas obligé de perdre contre cailloux
quoi
l'art ils ont changé de joueuses à la
première c'était eux
c'était shuvalova l'a perdue ils ont mis
garufi luna
que j'avais battu en pro-chasse flic
d'ailleurs gare au feeling
et qui a besoin les cinq tours ces deux
l'impression que ça tourne plutôt pas
mal pour les russes pour le monde pourra
les chinois pour le moment
mais je ne sais pas
ce que je pense pouvoir vaz à la
cheville ça dépend de la cadence en
blitz oui après en longues sûrement pas
on joue plus du tout - depuis longtemps
peu bizarre les places des pièces de de
ding quand même ici
impossible à suivre en fait le match je
sais pas comment le commenter
correctement ce qu'il faut regarder un
petit peu tout mais quand on regarde un
peu tout on n'a rien de temps de voir
mais tu continues à t'entraîner pour
avoir au niveau genre théorie et ou en
vidéo youtube mes vidéos youtube déjà
c'est pas de l'entraînement ça
n'entraîne pas j'ai pas le temps à choix
mais je sais pas trop comment commenté
en fait cet événement je n'arrive pas à
comprendre
parce que
il ya trop d chic et partout en fait
à prendre en dessin que les deux époux
b5 aucune idée schéma plus de quel parti
tu parles en fait
je sais pas en fait honnêtement je ne
sais pas je sais pas comment m'en sortir
il ya trop de choses en même temps ici
sûrement pourquoi pas prendre en d5
ok c'est pas facile qui va les prendre
c'est interdit par les règles du jeu
d'échecs
et d'amour
en d5
et surtout prend fou prend dam des
saints qui aura poussé trois donc tu
peux pas vraiment le prendre
quand est ce que je chaque bras quand
j'avais 10 à 18 ans je vais jouer à
23,50 24 juge arrêté très tôt j'ai pas
eu le temps de prendre les points l'eau
puisque les coefficients sont très lents
je devais jouer ça va je faisais que des
pertes dans ce raid jeu là en fait je
faisais que des perfs même entre 24 30
et 24 81
la partie de dubai avait pas de fourbes
et 5 en fait il n'ya jamais eu trouver 5
le fou et là il n'a jamais pu atterrir
ici
et ça répétaient les couvrent des deux
cavaliers six f4 car il a agi sans une
tête qui va mettre le fois en c1 pour le
passé en v2 ou à trois
fo 3
à faire cavaler f6 tour c'est un je
pense
c'est là on leur dit joue quand même fou
c'est un pur four b2 ici le foot doit
être tellement bien placé sur la grande
diagonale
mais dur à comprendre
on va voir ça peut faire draw ici
hier mon téléphone qui sonne 8 secondes
dans mon cas
ça continue oui le défi c'est marrant
ici
pense qu'il va y avoir dame prend des 6
passes qui s'affaiblit droit par gs1 qui
va vouloir échanger les dames
enfin bref pour ceux chine-russie way
russie russie là ils ont gagné le
premier mini match on va espérer qu'il
gagne le deuxième s'éviter des
tie-breaks pour aller en finale
après l' avantage si la chine gagne
c'est que la finale sera le matin
sûrement ce qui laisse la journée libre
derrière quand même des arguments pro
chine aussi dur à dire
mais bon c'est avec éviter de taille est
vrai que c'est peut-être le mieux donc
quand même plutôt réussi là et après si
du coup si cyrus s'ils gagnent ouais
après mon sera
white sea shipping lines sera pour la
chine en tie break en fait
donc gare atx qui n'a willy fans
alpha n'y a rien à dire de plus ça joue
pas clair zhu hailun kosteniuk la petite
pression de joux
et soutiennent qu doit faire le taf pour
la russie c'est lui qui est plus fort
pièce de plus
même si la position est complexe il a
raison pouvoir chinois tout le bordel et
l'échiquier féminin junior qui avait
posé problème aux russes
voir si les ja fait mieux
ce
ouais là il peut y avoir du c5 des
quatre maintenant pour t'ouvrir
il faut calculer ça
peut-être sur ses seins qu'elle veut
cavaliers prendrait cinq ans fait
et prendre les cinq gars me prends des
saints qui a peut-être fou aussi
s'attaque la dame attaque le fou
complexe
complexe complexe
on va il a fait ce que j'avais dit
artemiev ça doit être confortable
du beauf qui l'a jours
c'est très chaud
c'est en doute partout en fait
la raison que les chinois sont calmes
légèrement devant mais bon il ya cet
échiquier des six pieds au qui doit être
en faveur de la russie
donc ouais c'est pas clair
c'est comme légères avantage chine pour
moi mon truc c'est qu'en cas d'égalité
c'est les russes qui l'emportent donc
forcément les rues sont devant
si lord il recommande de faire bk tu
comprends tout reprend fou prend et qui
a validé quatre pour ceux touchés la
case c6 difficile à voir
difficile à voir
même très difficile à voir il a fait
assez bien joué ça parce que c'était
vraiment pas facile
très franchement c'était vraiment pas
facile
benko qui a posé de gros problèmes à
magnus ici c'est lui
là c'était vraiment pas facile ça à
trouver
équipe de france elle s'est fait éliminé
il ya longtemps comme pour beaucoup
d'équipés les meilleurs joueurs étaient
absents de cette compétition
donc quand je pense aux meilleurs
joueurs je pense à ahfir ouja mvele
ça tu affaiblis quand même beaucoup
quand il monte deux meilleurs joueurs un
surtout dans un format 15 + 10 tu mets
tuméfié rue jive elle s'est quand même
pas la même
quoi sur cbs c'est ce que j'expliquais
tour processeur qui a aidé 4 ric6
allez faut que comme je sens que la
russie peut gagner faut que je mette la
petite pub pour être bien sûr d'obtenir
les six minutes de pub leur mettre une
sur deux heures désolé les gars là petit
tube qui part
pous pareil
d'ailleurs il pousse
et le cavalier arrivant des quatre
à bas une petite pub qui part ça fait du
bien
et la foi f4
la petite pub qui fait plaisir
ah non sur ma chaîne jeu mais pas je
fais pas vu comme ça ça sert à rien
c'est abusé en fait moi j'aime pas qu'on
mette autant de tubes donc je le fais
pas sur ma chaîne gens mais de temps en
temps on en met une minute toutes les
trois heures de pur
je dois en mettre une minute mème pas
peut-être toutes les trois heures
peut-être même moins je devrais en
mettre plus d'ailleurs quand il ya des
temps morts
ouais non ça a l'air d'aller pour la
russie en fait ce que double file a une
belle position
grillage qui n'a elle tient plutôt ya
kosteniuk est un peu en danger
mais soutiennent qu est bien
non ça se passe plutôt bien pour la
russie a rien à dire on va voir comment
ça évolue
on va voir comment ça évolue
le problème c'est que j'ai trente
secondes de délai parce que parce que le
stream il est surtout une chaîne youtube
en même temps donc pour faire ça ça me
met un délai et à cause du délai jeu et
comme il faut tourner d'échiquier pour
voir le match en faites pas je ne sais
pas quelles questions vous posez donc
c'est pour ça que je peux pas répondre
malheureusement
c'est pour ça que malheureusement je
peux pas répondre c'était sur gages qui
n'avait peut être que c'est déjà passé
quoi
après y'a des pions d'oublier à des
pions doubler ici une structure un peu
faible on verra le truc c'est qu'il faut
regarder un peu tous les échiquiers pour
comprendre ce qui se passe on obligé de
cliquer en fait
ça donne le tournis même c'est le format
qui veut ça c'est format révolutionnaire
un peu oui et parce qu'en fait ils
disent ait note sur garde qu'une partie
ça sert à rien tu veux savoir un peu
tout
une graine et dans la sauce sécher pas
il est peut-être moins bien vrai
vraiment il ya rien de décisif nulle
part
autre problème en fait c'est que le
temps on n'a pas les bons temps
oui je préfère comme ça c'est plus
dynamique ouais ben oui oui
ouais non non c'est chaud
là il suffit plus que d'attendre en fête
et voir ce qui va se passer
sur le truc officiel je sais pas il
regarde encore le troisième coup d'une
partie quoi ces terribles ils reprennent
les parties du début en fait un truc
extraordinaire
c'est qu'il regarde les parties du
premier coup faites suivre pas du tout
match en fait sur le truc officiel ils
s'en foutent complètement
moi j'essaie vraiment de suivre quand
même même si je trouve que ça sert
vraiment à rien j'essaye vraiment de
comprendre qui va gagner mais a
vu glg le
g le live en eau en fait ils suivent à
ils suivent pas le match du tout faty
suivent voient ils sont sur des 4 des 5
c 4 6 qui a et c 3 c'est terrible
ok là ça ça va faire nul c'est sûr ça
c'est signé ok une première nul signé
c'est digne du boeuf non non non ça
c'est pas digne du boeuf c'est digne du
boeuf de la première ronde pardon pas
deux nuls signé désolée
qu'elle a il peut y avoir d'yeux
quattrocchi par cavalier prend fou prend
key c6 ok si do bumba ding ça va mal
pour la chine parce que c'est un point
qu'on n'avait pas compté allez c'est
peut-être là le match qui s'emballe un
peu la victoire de double up peut forcer
tous les chinois à se découvrir
en fait ça normal parce que aulas il ya
du fou j'ai sinko qui part elle pourrait
marquer deux points là les russes sur
les six pianos et sur dubai filler
manquerez deux nuls sur quatre parties
bref j'ai cinq classes et termine à dos
et échangent des dames et a plus rien ça
peut faire déjà de zaire rapidement
avec celle là qui est complètement nul
ça peut faire deux et demi il manquera
une nulle en trois parties sur les 3,3
partie où les rues sont un peu en
difficulté
on va avant
ce qui m'inquiète pour les russes s'est
garé poulina quand même à moins qu'ils
aient un bug mais elle tente du temps
depuis un moment ok
voilà que j'appuie sur refresh elle a
vraiment fait dame c5 ici il ya
peut-être missclick
non j'y crois pas
non non non ya pas missclick
il ya eu erreur de retransmission
c'est pour ça que ça avançait pas la
partie a eu erreur de retransmission
mai
ça donne quoi apposition
salaire très cool pour la joueuse russe
ici aussi j'ai l'impression qu'à russe
on vient de partout
parce que là ça va être fou prend qui on
prend cavaliers sait si ce qui est
français s'ils souffrent des six clouage
ça ça va être super yong hi ça va être
égale ça c'est mieux pour la joueuse
chinoise
ça c'est mieux pour la jeune chinoise ya
peut-être deux points pour la chine de
points pour la russie
ça peut se jouer sur l'échiquier junior
féminin une nouvelle fois
qu'elle a ses trois sets prend pions et
clou là ça se passe vraiment bien pourri
six pieds n'co même matériellement il ya
quoi cinq pions scipion 2 4 5 wen an qui
là un pion pour la pièce s'est même pas
ça ça va gagner ici
ça ça à faire un point ça va faire deux
points ça va faire deux points et demi
gharyan china ou je sens bien gharyane
qui n'a perdre en fait tu
prends la gaffe qui a rédigé quatre et
au noir comment on continue
énorme gaffe de gharyane skinn as les
chinoises reviennent un peu dans la
partie
très haut noir
dit qu'il n'a pas
aidé nous qui la fout pranger deux rois
projet de dames des cinq
qui est cède
il faut projet de saab endroit si el
afou pranger de et reviennent dans la
game
circé à la foux projet de la chine
revient complètement sans moment clutch
les amis
c'est un moment clutch
elle n'a pas elle n'a pas c'est pas dans
son daniel à la championne d'action
plein du monde numéro un mondial c'est
dommage quand même parce que c'est une
pièce en deux coups un
mais oui
elle l'a pas
pas dans le daniel de willy fans
donc ça veut dire que ça relance
[Musique]
sa relance un peu guerrier hadj qui n'a
même si c'est dur
ça va être termine à dos
et s'ils prennent qu il fait le taff
savage sur cet échiquier en fait
ça passe par une victoire de cailloux
pour pour la chine
tu penses
ça passe par une victoire de cailloux
voilà tout va se jouer en même temps en
fait parce qu'ils ait note de partout
partout donc ça va ça va tout va se
terminer en même temps on va rien voir
en fait
well as
une victoire de cailloux ouais
bon dame sarret dam des deux ça calme en
fait fait aller moins bien qu'ils
aillent où je pense pas qu'elle gagne ou
alors un miracle shading ou un truc
comme ça et leur faut un petit miracle à
la chine pour rester en vie
après c'est que s'ils doivent gagner que
ici pierre ngo gagne ça fait quand même
deux points
ça fait cher hein ça fait cher
on va faire tour 3 et f6
ça à partir avec francky on prend
dame g4 menacera car l épreuve 6
ça c'est le punto
gacina qui est toujours mal devrait
perdre kosteniuk qui devrait perdre
ça va vraiment joué sur cailloux en fait
ça va jouer sur un choc possible
ça peut jouer là dessus
ouais faut b3
normalement ça va passer ça ça ne doit
pas perdre mais bon après c'est quand
même les chiots les joueurs sont plus
faibles tout peut arriver
caillou à deux doigts de perdre un
heureusement qu'à la foulée car je pense
qu'elle n'avait pas dans son daniel un
full méca d'amd un four
heureusement qu'elle est là parce que vu
le rythme de jeu je pense qu'elle avait
pas dans le daniel
voilà
six dames 17 ça va terminer le truc
jours
il se retrouve à être même moins bien
contre artemiev donc si ça va pas du
tout
car elle a une petite chance de tenir
comme kosteniuk mais les deux les deux
parties sont difficiles
et six pieds en cause ces pièces de plus
avec le pion passé
faire roi des deux et
il va encaisser la tour donc lui ça fait
point
du boeuf sa fait le poteau donc il ya
deux punto et demi pour la russie
il manque une drôle ici en fait
il reste le punto le poteau de l'eia
il reste le punto
à aller chercher
une petite dron
petit d'en haut
c'est terrible
menace d'un match 5
va être obligé de sacs et la dame mais
ça va être perdant
ça défend bien quand même ok par contre
carnage qui n'a c'est la cata
j'ai trop fort
elle veut défendre avec fous j'ai trois
en réalité ouais ça peut jouer sur un de
choc de la junior fille c'est souvent
l'échiquier qu évident quand tu veux que
ça tu choques
souvent sur le junior fille
c'est chic et sur lequel tu peux le plus
faire choke mais
hélas à cette dame qui atteint 8 ça
s'est terminé 12e c'est le point et me
et six pianos le point et me
donc ça fait deux points il en manque
plus qu'un
bon là ça va faire 2 1 ça à faire 2 2 il
reste deux échiquier en réalité
mais maintenant ces poussettes pour
artemiev
à les russes vont peut-être même pas
avoir besoin
du demi point de l'échiquier féminin
junior féminin mais bon c'est celui
qu'on va regarder
ok elle tente le tout pour le tout
caillou
est normalement dame eu trois rouages de
tours d2 pour ses 8,3 cette dame 8 en
cette chaude
à chuck faut aller mater fait quoi elle
fait quoi
au nom au lieu de showkhi par once à ces
deux coups de ce battle à 1200 au stade
choc c'est n'importe quoi
ah non mais mètres la tour en est fluide
c'est grave en fait mais c'est ce que je
vous ai dit quand vous voulez faire dans
cette compétition faut viser le junior
féminine
parce que ça peut choquer hockey est en
france s est pressée 7 et envoie ton
pions non
ça peu de choc
allez-vous au 5 allée cailloux cailloux
qui fait pas à oui mais c'est cool parce
que maintenant sur a3 ya damas huit pros
c'est terrible à l'as pas vu elle n'a
pas vu le pion de l'eia c'est pas
possible
alors la série de coups à 1200 quoi ou à
911 c'est terrible on se croirait dans
une samba talent au nom mais là c'était
vraiment incroyable
elle a échangé les change pas on sait
cet alléchant jean bessette pour se
prend des chèques et ça ça se joue là
dessus ces olympiades
a par contre ici intéressant sur ouachin
la un stand d'euros
à ses terres c'est qu'elle doit faire
nul c'est terrible
et ça ne choque
pas ça les grands maîtres ou pas mais
c'est terrible halléguen m
là c'est vraiment une série de coups
hoymille cent mille deux cents
c'est terrible de ne pas tenir la
pression comme ça
quatre cinq coups à 1000
avec un peu de bol il ya un geste inco
ici qui passe
je pense à la haye la dame c41 qu'adam
c4 salaire de bien finir
elle s'est bien ressaisi
au terrible
il a raté ma tondeuse
assez terrible
ça choque
san jose 2 ou fla
il était pas à voir mais quand même à ce
niveau là tu dois le voir
tu peux pas rater
j'avais la turbine est en partie
j'aurais pu le voir mais j'aurais raté
j'aurais été très énervé après moi même
dans ces trucs là le roi 5 a été moins
thématique le tour ces deux j'ai pas
trop compris comment elle a raté mais ça
c'est possible
avait clairement c'est la force d'un ak
un accueil rate rien n'à qu'à ça et le
voit tempo donc et victoire de accosté
du prix à gagner
mais c'est incroyable ça c'est
magnifique commence à gagner pu gagner
il ya eu le choc de joe and john
c'était complètement gagnant
elle a fait n'importe quoi jouer
ouais bon bah là ça fait déjà 3 0 donc
s'est terminée en le match est gagné
pour la russie
c'est pour ça que ça arrêtez de choke
côté les ya des kosteniuk a été gagnante
en fait s'arrêter deux chocs
ouais ça fait trois erreurs
oui fans à la grille nationale la finale
technique mais en gros à
remettre de 7,0 en fait finale
la russie a gagné 2,02 7
08 heures de dubai kosteniuk et s'ils
prennent qu'aux
nuls
2-2 gaga au final nul de dart nf donc
ils ont raison ils ont déjà 4 ha ça va
faire 4 2
on va du coup les gars prochain match à
17h on va pouvoir faire une pause on va
pas attendre belle victoire de la russie
une petite pause quand même de trois
minutes la petite pub de trois minutes
qui part je vous dis à tout à leur merci
à tous 17h30 pour le prochain match
bonne pub j'ai envie de vous dire
magnifique pub je vous souhaite de vous
faire plaisir sur cette magnifique pub
qui part et qui va vous divertir
et je vous dis à tout à l'heure pour la
suite merci à tous
je vais attendre la fin de la partie
malheureusement
attendre cette partie se finissent même
si elles servent plus à rien
c'est complètement gagnant un meilleur
on a même réussi à respecter les pubs
wef partie pas passionnante à sans enjeu
en plus
tout
complexe
complexe complexe
ça fait 3 g de f3 de f1
ça devrait abandonner
et merci à tous la partie est finie
victoire du oui fans victoire de la
russie
4 buts à 2
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve
retrouve on se retrouve